it's another day gone by as Kish FMA
returns home from A Hard Day's Work she
works as a housemid working in several
homes but she's not done for the day
dinner tonight is a cup of tea without
milk and plain bread the Widow with four
children huddles around a fire fueled by
Twigs she's still in shock after seeing
the electricity
bill see this I've got a bill for 18,500
but I only earn 15,000 rupees per month
how will I pay it I have only one fan
and two energy saver bulbs how can the
bill be so high I hardly ear enough to
provide food for my children if I pay
this bill how will I feed my children
the higher electricity bills aren't
solely due to increased energy cost but
also because of higher taxes imposed by
the government after 3 days of high
level meetings by government ministers
in Islamabad there's no solution to the
crisis says for the past few days
protesters all across Pakistan have
burned their electricity bills and said
they're refusing to pay them the
government says consumers have no choice
but to pay their bills however for
millions of people across Pakistan that
is an option will beond their
means Traders and businesses are already
closing shop and have announced a plan
for a Countrywide protest against the
price rise the industry
IND factories and businesses are on the
verge of collapse many have already shut
down record high inflation has also
reduced the people's purchasing power
and the markets are
empty as word spreads about Al jaaz
being here in this poor neighborhood
others bring along their unpaid bills to
complain we are in a difficult situation
and our husbands are jobless which makes
us find work so we can support our
families
like many others she says spending a
huge amount for her power bills is Way
Beyond her ability to pay pan ska
government is now having to contend with
widespread discontentment and growing
protest and that may well spin out of
control Kamal haer Al jaaz Islamabad